وجود جار مثل روسيا يبقي
فيتوس غودينسكيس مستيقظًا في الليل مسلحًا بمدفعه الرشاش وجحر مالطي
،
فهو حرفياً خط الدفاع الأول
إذا اتخذت قوات الكرملين في نهاية
شارعه خطوة واحدة على
أرض الناتو حيث تبدأ روسيا نعم الروس
في  نهاية شارعك ، نعم ،
يقول فيتوس إنه يستطيع رؤية الجنود بعد حلول
الظلام بنظارات الرؤية الليلية الخاصة به ،
ويشير إلى ميدان رماية فوق التل ،
وغالبًا ما تسمع الطلقات التي يقول من
هناك أن
الاحتلال السوفيتي هو ذكرى شخصية عميقة
في هذا الجزء من أوروبا  يقول فيتوس إن
والده كان من بين
ربع مليون ليتواني تم إرسالهم إلى
معسكرات الاعتقال حيث لقى الكثيرون حتفهم ،
لذلك عندما ضمت روسيا شبه جزيرة القرم
وانضمت إلى ميليشيا متطوعة تاريخية في ليتوانيا ،
كان اتحاد الرماة الذي يديره
قائد إقليمي يائسًا أيضًا
لتجنب العودة إلى الحكم الروسي للجميع.
لديه نفس القصة ،
تم
إطلاق النار على شخص ما من قبل السوفييت ، على سبيل المثال من قبل
النظام السوفيتي أو سانتو سيبيريا أو
لمجرد أنهم
كانوا ليتوانيا
تضاعفت عضوية
البندقية عشرة أضعاف منذ أن بدأت الحرب في أوكرانيا
، صغارًا وكبارًا ، حريصين على تدريب
كل مواطن ليتواني يعرف أن روسيا تشكل
تهديدًا كما يقول هذا المجند الجديد في الثلاثينيات من عمره
، وفي هذا الجزء من دول البلطيق الجنوبية ،
يبدو هذا التهديد حقيقيًا للغاية.  أنا أقف
على ما يُعد حاليًا أحد
أكثر الحدود سخونة في العالم داخل أراضي الناتو ،
إنها قطعة أرض تسمى
ممر سوالكي بين ليتوانيا
وبولندا والتي تقع أيضًا إلى الغرب
هنا بين كالينينغراد
البؤرة الاستيطانية شديدة التحصين النووية في
روسيا ، وهناك  حليف
الكرملين على بعد 60 ميلاً في هذا
الاتجاه ، الخوف هو أنه إذا سقطت أوكرانيا ،
فإن جيش روسيا يمكن أن يتدحرج
هنا ، قلنا دائمًا أننا بحاجة
إلى قوات حلفاء إضافية داخل
الأراضي الليتوانية في حالة محاولة السيد بوتين أو
أصدقائه شيئًا ما
لتحرك ليتوانيا  أدى منع عبور
بعض البضائع إلى كالينينغراد إلى زيادة
المخاطر تمامًا كما التقى قادة الناتو
وروسيا ح  نظرًا لأننا تم الرد بالفعل على
الهجمات الإلكترونية المستمرة ، فقد بدأنا
نشهد زيادة ومزيد من
الكثافة في الأنشطة السيبرانية ضد
مؤسسات دولتنا ضد بعض
المشغلين المهمين وخاصة النقل ،
مدركين أنه قد يحصل على طلقة واحدة فقط
لحماية البلطيق ، فإن التحالف
سيضاعف الآن أكثر من 3000  القوات
المتمركزة هنا اليوم عند
وصولهم ، سيكون الرماة جاهزين ،
فنحن مستعدون للقتال مع الناتو جنبًا
إلى جنب مع الناتو كتف إلى كتف
ويؤمن زملاؤه المتطوعون
بحماية الناتو ولكنهم يعيشون
بالقرب من روسيا وعليهم أيضًا أن يكونوا
مستعدين لأي شيء
تريده.